and as promised we are back now with
comedian Sebastian Maniscalco and his
family pediatrician the real one Dr
Scott Cohen they are co-host of the
podcast daddy versus doctor where they
share advice from the father's
perspective and find comedy in
Parenthood and Vlad is also here at the
table as he continues to prepare to
become a dad any day any lots of
preparations going on 10 days to go all
right good morning to all I'll take the
first question here Sebastian you were
talking about what uh your kids eat and
what they don't eat and how you're
pretty strict about it where they eat it
you like to mince it up you don't want
any choking hazards but are there
particular foods that you would really
like from a health point of view to get
your kids to eat and they just won't do
it
well listen I think everybody wants
their kids to eat some type of green
vegetable and they're like well how do
we do that some people blend it in a
smoothie I don't care what you're
blending in a smoothie kale tastes like
kale all right
that's a fact and then some people go oh
you know what in order for you to have
your kids eat why don't you make the
pancake or whatever look like a bunny
you see a lot of these people trying to
like take food and make it look like
something else again if it tastes bad I
don't if it's the money they're gonna
spit the money ear out so Dr Cohen I've
I've heard from my my pediatrician to
try the shapes uh and the smoothies okay
and also the airplane move open the
hanger all day long what do you got for
me given that Sebastian's just dumping
on all that right I mean I don't have
the airplane move like Sebastian has
that's that's my you know he has the
go-to but I I think variety early on is
the key and one of the biggest changes
we saw in Pediatrics over the last
decade is how we introduce solid foods
and what we used to do before and you
probably heard this was very
conservative one food at a time cereal
for three days vegetable for three days
fruit for three days holding on more
allergenic foods like eggs and fish and
peanut butter till later and what we
learned is early introduction of a wide
variety of foods especially allergenic
Foods did two things create a better
eater because you're getting used to the
foods and the taste that you use in your
house even the bunnies and it decreases
allergies and all these kids remember
when we were kids nobody had allergies
and now you can't go to school with
peanut butter sandwich we actually
caused that because we didn't sensitize
kids to Foods early on so from day one
you can make your smoothie of eggs
shellfish peanut butter yogurt of course
not but the point is from day one
anything you can make non-choking they
can have except we say no honey till a
year I was eating squid at three years
old squid wow come from an Italian
family they just gave me everything
well okay so Dr Cohen on the podcast you
admitted that your daughter had mac and
cheese several times a week and I was
thinking about that about building
healthy eating habits my mom when I was
a kid growing up we didn't have any
cakes desserts sweets we didn't have
sweets after meals and as a result as an
adult I'm not I never crave those things
I never go to birthday parties and just
house the kids pictures
but that shaped who you are as an adult
and it did so how do you I I don't know
if that's an example of building healthy
eating habits but you're saying I lead
by such a good example right this is
what we do you know it's it's the the
pediatrician advice and then when you're
in your home what really happens as a
parent often very very different I
remember when my daughter my daughter
would put anything in her mouth when we
started food except for food and then
one day we're holding my wife is holding
a pickle and a potato chip and my
daughter reached over and licked the
pickle and licked the potato chip and
let the no wonder she likes salt ever
since so you know we talk about variety
and after a year of age even the best
eater is what ends up happening and I
joke but it happens about 100 of the
time they live off Dairy carbs and fruit
and that's sort of just the Staples you
still try all the other healthy foods
you try a variety you offer three or
four things you hope your child eats
part of one but you don't want to make
it a thing because you don't want to
make a fight over food because if it
becomes an issue later on and I think if
you offer variety you model you have
lots of different foods in your house
that you're eating and that they're
trying it ends up working out down the
road
Sebastian I'd really appreciate it
Sebastian you had a proud dad moment
your five-year-old Serafina had a
recital so she hit the stage like pops
what was that like watching that I
listen I I'm biased I think we have
another Entertainer in the family uh of
course I got extremely emotional
watching my daughter knock out these
these songs and it was just nice I mean
at five years old for her to have the
confidence to go up in front of a room
full of strangers and start singing I
mean I wasn't even doing that so I think
she's having a ball with uh with her
little theater group and uh yeah we you
know I told my manager I think we got
another client coming up the ranks here
and your manager was like I'll start
taking 20 percent
uh look guys we really appreciate you
being on uh and sharing all your
triumphs and fails as real life dads in
the world so it's beneficial for all
benefits
we'll have you back uh very soon new
episodes of daddy versus doctor Premiere
every Friday we'll be right back